[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
hello hello hello and welcome to our
portfolio site review let us know in the
chat where you're tuning tuning in from
I cannot wait to get started um please
make sure that this is an awesome
welcoming place um we want to have a
conversation with you guys so please
please please be active in the chat um
it's that it's that magic that happens
when everybody can talk to each other so
let us know where you're where you're
coming from and I just want to say hello
to Stephanie thanks for joining me today
oh so hell
hello all
right let's see we've got Cleveland Ohio
we've got France New Jersey Denver
Puerto Rico Stephanie we're going
worldwide today
worldwide no
[Laughter]
pressure is this going to be recorded to
watch at a later time I believe so yeah
yep Amsterdam Diego from Venezuela hello
Cleveland right on man it's so good
seeing all of you it's been a while
since we've done a a stream on this
channel and Stephanie is this your first
live
stream on YouTube on YouTube on YouTube
yes oh I'm excited this is gonna be fun
so like I said no pressure no pressure
no pressure at
all oh hi
Seattle familiar lots of familiar faces
in the chat as well to see all of you
Asher hope you're doing
well Spencer Hopkins representing
Texas and
Ashley are the streaming backgrounds
real yes matter of fact we have the same
camera set up up right finally I was I
was like oh man I need to get my camera
set up here we we'll do this we'll do
this
number bam depth the
field I just moved so I have nothing
behind me but someday it'll look great
it'll look great but right now it's just
a
wall thanks I mean this is the business
that we're in so it helps to have the
the the the cool look can set up all
right should we get into it let's go we
should we begin let's get into the goods
that's why we're here all right so today
let's take a look at uh what we are
going to cover make sure my slides are
working give me a thumbs up in the chat
if you can see the slideshow it should
be right
there oh I forgot there's a delay in
this all right so I I'll have to keep
that in mind
yes the wall is made of wall it's made
of
wall all
right enough chatting let's talk about
what we're going to cover today so we're
going to go through some
introductions um we're going to cover
the criteria and goals that we have for
our portfolio review today and then
we've got this great three question
self-critique guide that will help you
critique your own portfolio um because
we don't always have somebody to bounce
that off of and I'm really excited about
that part and we've got some website
reviews now before we dig in I want to
remind you that during this live stream
and only for those of you who are tuning
in live we're going to be sharing an
extra special deal with you Steph should
we tell them what the deal is yeah isn't
it the biggest it's the biggest deal of
all black of all the seasons of savings
right yes all right so literally the the
the the only time we've ever done a sale
like this no this is nuts so for we're
gonna give you a coupon code at some
point in this live stream and it is only
good for seven minutes so you have to
use it during the live stream and you
can get 70% off of any course kit
product at the future not membership
memberships not memberships not
memberships no we're talking courses
resources even merch so if you got your
eye on the poster or you want to jump in
illustration for designers these are the
seven minutes to do it and we'll tell
you when we're going to activate that
all right so so figure out figure out
what you want to buy everybody that's
right head Toth future.com shop and you
can peruse while we uh while we take a
look at some websites but before we
begin it does include the course bundles
yes yep oh it's good idea
right all right before we dig into
somebody's website um there might be
some people who don't know who we are so
let's take a minute to introduce
ourselves my name is Ben Burns I am a
designer by trade and I love making
things but my passion is to help
creative people just like you make a
living on your own ter terms now I coach
and teach creatives who are at the
beginning of their Journey find Traction
in their businesses and the last decade
for me has been an absolutely wild ride
I went from being a Narcotics agent to
having a my own design freelance
business to starting my own studio and
I've also gone to join on the incredible
team at blind and now I find myself in
the fortunate position to help chriso
take the future from Vision to reality
as the COO here now I hope that you all
have had the opportunity to meet her by
now because she should need no
introduction whatsoever she is my
co-author for accelerator and a rockstar
both literally and metaphorically and
happens to be our director of Education
here at the future I'd like to introduce
Stephanie
Owens hey everybody so I'm Stephanie uh
like Ben said the education director
here at the future I've been an educator
for over 20 years believe it or not and
I I help head up our courses in our
accelerator program but I'm also a
creative just like you guys I do have my
own Studio gold cheep design that I run
with my husband he is the illustrator to
my lettering artist the bass player to
my guitar player and we've worked with
lenes for Marvel DC recently Star Wars
really happy about that one and in and
you know in the work I do with the
future I I love helping creatives Rock
their portfolio and turn it into a lead
generating machine so that's what I'm
really passionate about my little corner
of how I like to help all of you guys uh
here at the future all our future
friends that's right that's me everybody
give uh Steph a round of applause in the
chat thank you so much for for joining
us here today um speaking of today what
why today what brings us together here
on this day well as we mentioned before
and as you've probably seen there are
some crazy deals going on all month long
and we are calling it the season of
savings and right now as it is
throughout the entire month of November
you can save 25% on all of our courses
toolkits and resources and the thing is
is that we've got activities and events
going on like this one today all month
long so if you'd like a full walkthrough
of everything that we have going on
during the month of November head the
future.com seof savings you'll be able
to grab a copy of our lookbook that has
a detailed breakdown of the month's
events and some really cool like
do-it-yourself curriculums that have
been put together by Miss Stephanie
Owens here now this thing is absolutely
beautifully designed by our in-house
designer Min many of you have seen her
on the on the channel over the years and
it's got some stuff that you've never
seen before like those curric but also
testimonials and a letter from our
founder Chris doe so that's the reason
why we're here in front of you
today but really why we're here is to
help you make a living doing what you
love I mean that's kind of what we want
for Christmas we just want to be able
please don't sing Mariah Carey right now
though it is my goal every year to never
hear that song so please don't sing it
and it's going to be in my head now
thank thanks bet that's all we want I'm
just saying um Min is still with us Min
is awesome yes yeah and here's the thing
the way that we do this is by giving
away as much content as we can for free
and by putting a ton of effort into
creating courses and toolkits and
memberships that are going to help you
design and build the life that you want
now what Stephanie and I have been
working on all year is the future
accelerator program now this thing is a
beast it is a stepbystep blueprint
coaching program that includes video
content resources templates Community
Real World feedback on your work and
weekly coaching calls now we are 500
members strong and almost we're very
close Stephanie we're very very close
and so far we've been able to help folks
generate hundreds of thousands in
Revenue over the course of the last 10
months I mean we see wins every week of
somebody Landing a dream client $10,000
project $15,000 project and being able
to build the life that they want to live
and that this program is where all of
our website reviews have come from our
accelerator
members now when you join accelerator
you're going to have one goal in common
as as a group one job that you want your
website to do and that
is to generate leads and bring in more
work your website should work for you so
this this is the lens that we're going
to be looking at these websites today
not to get a job to get clients all
right so how are we going to evaluate
these portfolios well we put together a
pretty simple rubric to review first
can we understand what you
do like is it simple for us to to take a
look at your home page and say like oh I
understand how I can work with this
person or this this company number two
is there proof that you can do this
Stephanie how do we prove this to people
with the body of work portfolios case
studies you got to prove that you can do
what you say you can do you got to show
that tall enough to ride the ride yes
absolutely and the last thing is the
proof
compelling now okay that's a that's a $2
word I had to verify that I knew that
that was the right word for this but so
what do we mean the one that's the one
where it's like well what does that
mean what do you mean it's
compelling so let's let's let's get into
this what what what do we mean by
compelling number one do we have context
can we understand what are you trying to
accomplish with this project what was
the brief what were the design decisions
that were made along the way what were
the implications on the work number two
is this easy to
understand are you giving us hieroglyphs
to interpret throughout your case
study is there no words in your case
studies in your portfolio like have you
written things like have you all words
yeah or is it all words right have you
made it easy for me to understand the
work and I think that this is what uh um
patrula ronus was referring to in in
previous portfolio critiques when she
said are you empathetic have you written
these things for a client to understand
and then this is probably the the most
important one this last one here does it
Inspire want does it make somebody want
to work with you are the graphics so
drool worthy that they want to jump in
to a project with you or have you solved
a big enough problem for your clients
that it makes them want you to help them
with their problem right does it Inspire
that want or need and this is something
we talk about in accelerator a lot Ben
it's like you can be a combination of
Aesthetics and impact but you can also
be an impactful service that is not
Aesthetics driven and you can be a
service that is just Aesthetics driven
with no provable tangible impact either
of those are completely viable and there
are markets for both and so that's where
it's like is it the want and need is it
drool worthy or is it showing Major
Impact just making someone want it for
what they need in their business either
it be results driven or Aesthetics or a
combination of
both absolutely yep so circling back
around here's our criteria but there's
one little bonus thing that we'll pay
attention to and that
is are we catching your Vibe like do we
get a closer look at who you are your
personality right
the are do we
understand
your style or can we see what it would
be like to be an immediate with you or
to work with you so we want to see some
of that stuff but that's a bonus so I
know that that can be a tricky balance
to uh to strike that one's tricky but I
do want to say if you are an Aesthetics
play and you're not getting down into
impact with the work that you do this is
something that you should be striving to
work towards with every project that you
do because if you are an Aesthetics play
it is a lot of it is you're going to be
hired because of the Vibe of your
work that's right now these are really
tricky to answer on your own now and
we're going to go through some websites
and so you can see how we evaluate this
but this can be really tricky to do by
yourself and not all of us have
community of people that we can bounce
things off of not all of us have
creative directors that can give us
feedback on the work can be kind of
tricky to do on your own so how should I
evaluate my own portfolio my own work we
get this question a lot and and Steph
you've got an incredible like three
question
DIY uh criteria rubric for this you want
to share it yeah absolutely so this is
this is most definitely if if you're
going solo you don't have that Community
you don't have expert designers to to
tell you those little like really
nitpicky type things that are always
going to take your work to the next
level but you don't need to you don't
need to start there I want you to look
at all of your work get it all into a
place where you can see all of it
together uh a a mirror board is really
good for that you can also put
everything onto a private Pinterest
board if it's all on your website you
can't really see it all together so if
you put it all together and then look at
all of the individual pieces in your
portfolio does each piece show case the
skill level that you are at
today not the skill level that you want
to be at 5 years from now because
sometimes that gets us into like oh my
God my work isn't good enough and that's
not what we want your work is good
enough for where you are right now but
if you see like you know what that piece
is baller and these five no no they're
they're actually like really old and I
can do a lot better they're dragging
your work down so it's better to have
fewer quality pieces than just a bunch
of stuff just to prove that you did a
bunch of stuff by back in college or 10
years ago or even if it was at the
beginning of the year and you've been
like focusing on your craft this year so
give them a hug if they are not at the
skill level that you're at today and let
them go and then also does the project
bring you Joy now in my studio we we
burned everything down in 2020 because
we we had soul sucking clients and our
work was attracting more and more of
those same clients and so we were just
like you know what these projects didn't
bring us joy their quality work the
skill level is there but just the
clients just drove us nuts and they just
kept coming back they're like oh yeah I
saw this product there's something about
them that were just attracting the wrong
types of clients so if is there any
project amongst all of your work that
you're just like oh that
one get rid of it it's okay it's better
to start with fewer quality pieces that
also bring you Joy and then is this the
kind of work that you want more of if
you took on a project just to pay the
bills and we've all been there give us a
a heck yeah in the chat if you've like
yep taken on projects to pay the bills I
have Ben has and that's not necessarily
the type of work you want more of
because your portfolio will
attract the types of clients that is
represented within the portfolio and so
if you have projects you're like I
really never want to take on that kind
of project again don't show it because
it's just going to attract more of it so
only show the work that's at your skill
level that brought you Joy in the
process and that you would love to have
more of it and then you can have those
other projects in the archives they're
there maybe you want to resurrect them
someday but for now just start
simple and how I would do it on my
own I think it's I think it's important
to note that your portfolio is not meant
to be a historically accurate archive
right it's not meant to be some like
library of every single piece of work
that you've ever done because I can tell
you that there are so many projects that
I've worked on over the years that would
never even make it close to my portfolio
your portfolio website or your Studio
website is a sales tool and it should be
curated so that number one tip there
right or actually it's kind of all three
right does the work represent my current
level of skill did the project bring me
joy and do I want more work like
this if you can answer those questions
then that work belongs in the portfolio
and and just drive this home one my
mentor he's he's he's amazing I got my
hands on one of his outof print books
and I showed it to him I'm like hey I
found it it's very difficult to find and
he was like oh don't look too closely
there's some bad work in that book so
even the designers who we look up to and
we think are just icons of their craft
like they have that work too that
they're like oh don't show that that's
that was that was me a long time ago I'm
a much I'm a much better designer than
that now much better videographer
whatever whatever your cra is and even
they don't want people seeing it anymore
even though we look at it we're like but
it's so great so that also proves that
you don't have to be the greatest of the
greatest to attract really great client
work all right should we dig in should
we pull up a a website and go at it
absolutely okay here we are asking all
of these were already presubmit by our
accelerator members so another little
perk of being an
accelerator all right our first
one
is make the website bigger making it
bigger here we go how's that is that
good yeah
okay all right so this one is no ramble
and it's submitted by an accelerator
member Daniel pole and I'm going to
scroll through the the the homepage and
just kind of call out some things that
he's done really really nicely the first
is this hero section is awesome seeing a
video of design work is pretty rare
unless you're a motion designer or a
videographer and I think that you you've
hooked me here you've like instantly
made me want to scroll to learn more
because we've got process shots we've
got incredible uh final pieces things
are moving it's engaging so I can't say
enough wonderful things about this stuff
going on above the fold I'm already
seeing he does packaging without you
even
scrolling can we understand what Daniel
does yeah he does packaging Brett called
it out in the chat consumer packaged
Goods next one is there proof yep it's
right there he's already answered two
questions before he we even scroll
before we even scrolled yep so I love
this this uh we call it a Clarity
statement No ramble is an independent
design studio with a focus on brand and
packaging design from function to design
it's Crystal Clear he's not beating
around the bush it's not some
complicated thing that we have to unpack
or explain in a single also not making
any promises either yeah like that'll
make things pop off the shelf because
there's so much more to that kind of
impact than just how well the package is
designed there's marketing involved and
things like that he is just say he is
delivering the Aesthetics and he's not
over promising anything with this
Clarity statement which I
love that's right so let's keep
scrolling down so now we're proving
we're proving it even
more with a list of kind of featured
products I love that he has the work
right away yeah anytime I'm going on a
website and there's a bunch of text
before I get to work I'm like where 's
the work where's it at I start getting
nervous yep so we've got this lovely
little about
section and then some
secondary uh calls to action what I
think is really impressive is that he's
got this persistent navigation with a
call to action here free brand review
now I'm not 100% on a brand review as
the primary call to action I think I
would ra rather see something like start
a project or schedule a call or schedule
a meeting um I'm not sure how how many
clients that would have significant
budgets would click on this and and have
this discovery call or brand review
scheduled so I also think that he's
really driving home packaging on his
homepage and not necessarily branding
even though I know he does both
packaging is what we call his leading
service so I do feel like there's a
little bit of a disconnect between the
CTA and the main like what's really
being driven home on the homepage which
is the packaging design right
yep so we've got some uh content here
which is really nice I think that owned
content is super valuable um your
website is the one place where you can
control things and it's a it's a great
way to like publish your thoughts in a a
environment that you can control so I
like to see uh articles or videos or or
you know content posted on the site it
is also the best feeling in the world to
get leads and they said they found you
from a Google search that went from a
Blog to your services and I'm like yes
so that's the play there with the blog
yep so you can see here he's got get in
touch as his uh as his call to action
here which is great but let's let's
start getting into the work because I
think that um I think that the work is I
mean it's stunning Stephanie what what
project do you want to see more of fine
and
fedal fine and
fettle all right so we're in a case
study and once again I'm hooked things
are moving I'm engaged my eyeballs are
glued to the
screen and the thing is that I like like
that it ended I like that it stopped
because now I really want to scroll to
see yeah my eyes were were getting a bit
like oh oh oh and then I was like ah
okay such a good teaser
[Music]
yeah I think this is a really strong way
of showing colorways instead of showing
the actual colors in the CMYK and all of
that kind of stuff just showing the
colors used and showing the logo
in a way that you would in a style guide
on top of
images in different color ways using the
image inside of the logo like proper
usage of it showing out showcasing it
like that it's very very
strong I also want to call attention to
this too long didn't read section here
it's like here's what the company is all
right here's what we
did and just kind of like a Contin
of the the what we did I like that
there's information up here that's like
super easy to to digest for somebody
who's going really quickly and also the
the balance of text to imagery is really
nice through this case
study can you go up for a second sure I
need to take my glasses off because it's
super shiny up up up up up to the
services keep going so we've got brand
strategy visual identity naming and
packaging design I love that all of it
is
reinforcing what he said he does on his
homepage and you you have to make sure
that what you say you do on your
homepage those projects have what it is
you're proving what it is you say you do
now if he had done something else like
photography and added that that would
have been totally cool I would call that
like a subskill or a a secondary service
that you provide once they're in the
door but he is he is sticking to the
skills and the creative services that he
said he provides on the
homepage I know it's like such a little
detail but I feel like there's a lot to
be said for that just making sure that
it's consistent with what you said you
offered on the
homepage yeah and I would hate for
anybody to wind up in a position where
they said that they can do something and
then they have no examples so then the
client comes to you and they're like hey
can I see work in I don't know
illustration and you're like oh I don't
have any but I could do some for you and
that makes the sale just so much harder
it's it's an awkward place to be in um
and this pay you no one wants to pay you
like a a a good fee for being your
guinea pig right it's like I feel like
at that point personal work something we
talk a lot about in accelerator and I
talk about in my course it's like the
Hallmark of getting started started the
majority of us can start with personal
work if we especially we want to Pivot
into or try a new skill bartering is
another great option and if espe
bartering and pro bono work like faux
free I've I've done it I've done the
bartering for sure have what have you
done Ben bartering pro bono oh yeah and
you know it's either free or full full
price for me so yeah I've done because
it's cool exactly so I feel like if you
are like that's where you need to show
proof is is doing it that way and not
like using a client as a guinea pig for
I think I could try
that nothing wrong with personal
work so one of the things that I I want
to call out here this is super super
nitpicky but the line length is a little
bit too long it's a
personal um little pet peeve of mine but
it makes it difficult to read when when
you've got this many uh characters in a
single line so it's okay Daniel my line
length is long too he's pointed this out
I pointed it out on Stephanie's side too
and I'm like it's okay I still get work
no one has ever not not wanted to pull
the trigger with us because our lines
were too long but it's it's a bism we'll
we'll let we'll we'll let him have them
so one of the things that I want to call
out here is how Daniel has taken the
core of the Brand This
Ampersand and done so many different
visuals that all feel
different and so you can see how this
company is able
to use the same shape the same form in
many different ways and so too often in
portfolios we'll see somebody have the
same logo just plastered on different
items like they'll show the same logo on
a hat and on a shirt and on a bag and on
a magnet and
I think that this is a really
interesting way that that he's taken the
form and done a whole bunch of cool
stuff with it so the work itself is
fantastic the visuals
are stunning I mean there's there's
nothing wrong with this it makes me want
to give him a call and I think this is
where Daniel has
paired Identity Design and branding
brand Identity Design with another
service like pack in and it makes it
very easy for people to see oh you you
do the identity to the packaging and
having that nice pairing there it also
makes it very clear to Daniel when he's
creating these mockups where that
Identity Design is going to live so
think about that even if it's a personal
project and you're doing brand Identity
Design for a madeup company really think
about where is that product going to
live in the world and make sure that
your mockups reflect that and not just a
go-to T-shirt and hat and things like
that which that's where it could live
there but where else could it live
because most of the time people don't
just want a logo to put on a T-shirt and
a
hat
yep Nate bot thank you for that I
appreciate
it it line length is a is a pet peeve
right got my
glasses thank you Nate
bot
so we can take another uh one more look
at a case study here they're all equally
wonderful um The Thing One Ben one of
Ben's tricks too and we don't
necessarily need to do it with all of
them is looking at the first one and the
last one yeah sometimes the last one
doesn't get as much love and we're like
but it's at the end does anyone really
going to look at that yes people are
going to look at your portfolio if
they're going to be paying you good
money so make sure every single
portfolio piece has a lot of love or
simplify your portfolio
yep so one thing I wanted to call out is
that all of the visuals are on brand for
the project and no ramble Daniel has
not pushed his
own brand his own Aesthetics into the
client projects but the thing is is that
they all fit on the site and I've seen
this before where the studios
branding just doesn't fit with some of
the client work that they're displaying
like the colors are clashing and all
this kind of stuff so not only do all of
his visuals feel like they're they're in
the same brand but they
also set well in the actual website the
website doesn't scream louder than the
work so wanted to call that out as as
something really really and I think this
this kind of gets into the Aesthetics
and the vibe it's is always very clean
he does minimal very uh sort of modern
work and you're not going to come to
Daniel
for illustrative like packaging with a
lot of illustration on it or maybe with
Custom Lettering on it but and he and
he's not promising that either so it's
really using your work to help position
you in the Marketplace too and the types
of work that you want to
attract because sometimes positioning
doesn't always have to come down to an
industry but it can be through your
style and your point of view like
Daniel's done here even if it's a very
simple modern clean style like this not
everything has to be
maximal that's just
me so I want to answer Russell's
question here you feel like it's worth
showing your face if you're in the the
main person owner or do you think we
language is important even though uh it
might not be the 100% truth all the time
Stephanie you have thoughts on this I
think it depends
on how you are positioning yourself you
do subcontract on occasion so saying we
is not a complete lie you do have people
that you work with if you are after
freelance work through larger
agencies I would recommend that if it is
just you to use I because then you
really are positioning yourself as their
Hired Gun if that is what you want to do
and there is absolutely nothing wrong
with doing it that way um if you want to
present yourself as more of an agency or
a studio with with a a network of
Freelancers that you subcontract to I
don't see a problem with we um but I I
do think that if you use we you are
excluding a possibility of working with
other a agencies unless it's a big
collaboration between the two agencies
which does happen on
occasion and and this is the magic of a
studio this is why I love the word
Studio to describe Design Services
basically creative services in general
because it's okay to have a one-person
Studio it's okay to uh to say I and yet
you have a brand name um and agencies
all over the place are quite frequently
hiring contractors and Studios to do
creative work so I that's that's why I
like Studio as a I guess a descriptor
for the kind of businesses that most of
us are are
running I want to um point out one other
thing that I think is really really cool
is that his navigation it's super clear
like the way that he structured the
website we know that when when we click
here we're going to see examples of his
work
about gives us like a more personal
relationship with Daniel and his uh his
Studio services this makes it really
easy for a potential client to
understand what you do and how they can
work with you so if we click into to
Brand design not only do we see more
information about brand design but we
also see
the work that he's done over the years
for brand design so I think it's a
really smart way to structure the site
the industries and then the contact page
folks please make it easy for someone to
contact you on your website it's so
crucially important I I just got done um
teaching a a website class in
accelerator and I found this incredible
studio um right here in South Carolina
it was uh in
Charleston this studio had in awesome
work I mean I was just blown away and I
clicked on their contact link and
nothing happened and I was like oh no I
I hope I hope that I'm the only one that
that error is happening to because man I
can't imagine how much business they're
missing out on and it was because it's a
simple mail to link
right they wanted you know someone to
click on contact and then have your
email program open up and that is that
is a risky move if there's no
alternative way to uh to contact you so
I love that thing opens I'm like no no
no no no always the wrong program right
or it has the wrong email associated
with it I
just that's just personal preference
maybe some of you love that but I'm just
like stop and then it starts uploading
all these emails I'm like no no no no no
no no I don't want that yes go away
yeah so I like that he's got a form here
I'm a big fan of web forms instead of
just an email address um because you can
pre-qualify um your lead and so he does
a little little bit of pre-qualification
here General inquiry and service inquiry
I think that this could probably be
stronger um he could be asking questions
like hey do you want to start a project
you have a deadline tell us about the
project that kind of thing um so there's
there's a little bit more that you can
do with this
form but he's also got um other ways to
contact down here which is
great you want to go anywhere else with
uh Mr Po's website here I just want to
point out that instead of the word
portfolio he has work I think this is
super tiny little detail but if we have
portfolio something in my brain click
student
work not sure why yeah and and a
portfolio yes if you are a design
student art student you do end up having
a portfolio and it's basically all the
work that you did in college but seeing
the word work is it just seems a little
bit more professional to me than having
portfolio yep all right we ready to move
on yeah let's go okay here we go
we're going from packaging and branding
over to the web here we've got this is
not my world but
I'll her work is great I already know
that it's it's fantastic so let's let's
go through this this website right off
at the uh above the hero right above the
fold before you have to scroll she says
hi I'm AA I do ux design and web flow
development for SAS
companies do we understand what she
does yes yes I mean I might not
understand what ux design
is but if I am a SAS company I probably
it's it's I know that it's not for me
and I know who it is for and what she
does so perfect your website should also
be attracting and repelling at the same
time yep that's I mean what I
think you should be attractive and
repulsive is what she's trying to say
ladies and gentlemen attractive and
repulsive I am very attractive to some
people and very repulsive to
others so right off the bat I mean
navigation is solid work Services about
blog and then start a new project great
call to action there strong strong I
like how there's a call to action right
here inquire about a new project she's
telling you her goal which is
fantastic I also like the transitional
call to action see how I can help so
it's like I don't know if I really like
want to work with you yet but maybe
let's like let me see what you have to
offer yep so not only is she very clear
in her Clarity statement I do ux design
and web flow development um but she also
kind of explains it in the form of what
I would say is more of an impact
statement I can help you design and
develop outstanding products that are
easy to navigate so you can grow your
Revenue fast see that I get and I think
it's really important to have something
on your website that strips it away from
the language of the design world and
makes it very crystal clear to clients
what it is you do and how you can help
them and even words like brand Identity
Design Identity Design brand strategy
not all clients get it so just saying
you do
branding while the overlords of design
might be like no you don't you just do
logos you need to write not for the
overlords of design but for your client
yeah so think about when you're writing
for your website and even when you're
introducing yourself to
people stripping away all of that kind
of curs of knowledge language that we
use and just make it super easy for
people to understand most people get
logo design most people get branding
even if you do just do logos and there's
nothing wrong with that telling other
people that you do branding or logos and
not getting into Identity Design might
be the power play because it and and for
here she has ux design for SAS but then
she simplifies it even more which is a
very strong move yep exactly so guys if
you're if you're getting value right now
do me a favor and just like the video
let us know in the chat that you're here
that you're alive that you're that
you're eating this up um or or tell us
to kick rocks either way either way we
just want to make sure that that this is
uh this is valuable to you all right
let's keep
scrolling Okay so we've got some
examples of work here let's see if we
can click
into oh okay
so the way that these things attract
attention
I would assume that this is
clickable and so I was clicking here and
nothing was happening so I'm not sure
about what I'm looking at and and that
might need to be solved now this could
just be like hey here's a here's a bit
of my work to kind of hook you in but
compared to what we were seeing on
Daniel's site I'm not feeling that in
instant draw I'm not feeling that like
ooh that's sexy
let me hook in let me click into that um
I would say at this point she has proof
yep it's there but right now it's maybe
not compelling because I haven't had an
opportunity to dig into it
yet yep all right so let's keep going
okay so we've got ux and product design
and web flow development so yet yet
again we've got we've got this lovely
micro interaction where these things are
are changing background color on on
Hover but I would love to be able to see
some of this stuff and and none of this
is clickable so from a design
perspective from Aesthetics this looks
really cool and it's very succinct so it
tells me exactly what kind of ux design
and product design and web flow
development services you're offering but
they look like buttons to me and so I
really want to click them really want to
click them so anywhere where you list
Services that's an opport Unity for a
potential client to click in and get
more details and see the work so make
sure that those things are uh linked to
examples because somebody's going to be
looking for proof at this point and
outside of this one image if this
aesthetically doesn't fit with what that
client is looking for by this point
they're probably going to bounce
out my brain immediately went to like if
you click on if you scroll up just a
little bit if you if you click on say
web design all the web design portfolios
will appear somehow even if it's like
filtered on screen or it sends me to a
page that's where my brain is thinking
because they do very much look like
buttons yeah so the expectation there
was like oh okay there's still no
there's still no compelling proof at
this point at this point
yep now I do want to point out that that
you know there's obviously some ux
things going on here but as far as Web
Design This is a gorgeous site it's so
beautiful like the typography the way
that we're using Color here it's it's
gorgeous so IGA is a really good web
designer and I'm I'm I'm excited to see
more work and the thing is is that like
if you are a web designer if you're a ux
designer if you're in that realm your
website has got to be good it's got to
be like best thing that you've ever made
um it's it's almost like if you're a
packaging designer that selfpromo piece
that you put out where you do your own
packaging for something like like Farm
design and their popsicles it's got to
be good so web
designers heed the call all right yeah
and and all of you non- web designers
don't feel the need
to build out a custom website I'm I'm
all about getting your website done and
clean as quickly as possible especially
if you are not in web if you are in web
you better bring but if if if you're not
your work is the star should just be a
clean simple website that shows off your
work and allows you to talk about your
work that's that's what we're going for
yep all right so now we've got some more
proof and and based on my cursor change
we've got clickable items here so we'll
dig into that in a second here oh look
at here we've got a call to action right
on the homepage I like that some people
might say that it's too soon for this
but I actually like that because it
saves me a click if I've scrolled down
to this point and I've seen enough work
to be able to say like yeah I want to
contact you boom it's right here you're
cutting out one click no I don't think
it I don't think it's too soon either
it's sort of like you're a
business you're you're a business you're
in business to get clients so why would
you hide your cash register I mean this
isn't the literal cash register but why
would you hide it you wouldn't put it in
the The Dressing Room you wouldn't like
make it no no no I don't want people to
contact me you want people to contact
you so putting it on the homepage that's
what businesses you can either do it or
not but it's it's not a a gross move to
put it on the homepage yeah so we've got
some more proof here we've got some
client testimonials which is great it's
good to see those on the homepage
definitely recommend it
um make sure you're asking for
testimonials it can feel awkward but
it's totally a part of doing business
with service providers when you're done
with the project ask them what was the
best part about about the project and
when they tell you ask them if you can
write up a testimonial and then send it
to them for approval based on what they
just said that's the hack it's really
really easy way to kind of work it into
a conversation but make sure you're
pulling testimonial
she also did something that I love and
this this may just be a step ISM put a
picture of the person that said the
quote yes I really like that because it
lets me know like oh those are her
clients you know I feel like you know
you it's a it's kind of a Vibe thing
even though she's not really a Vibe play
She's she's more of an impact play as
her Clarity statement said but it just
sort of sets the tone for like the type
of people she works with and puts more
faces in Humanity to the
brand
yep okay cool so that was the homepage
let's take a look at some work what do
you want to
see let's go to the last one let's go to
the last one digital quality assurance
handbook she's got three on the homepage
I like that
yep and that's really all you need you
need three projects in your portfolio as
a minimum um I don't think that there is
is a maximum if you do have I would say
more than 10 you want to kind of find
some way to help your users your
potential clients find what they're
looking for really fast so filters
search categories Services page that
kind of thing um but at a minimum you
just need three so if you're waiting for
that 17th project to put on your website
don't get the site up and running so you
can get to work and coming from someone
who has a lot of projects on her website
I like the idea of there is no maximum
because sometimes people say no no no no
just keep it simple keep it to five
there's keep it simple has a lot of
different meanings and keeping it simple
could mean you are showcasing a certain
craft and that's how you're keeping it
simple but you can show multiple
projects but if you are have if you have
diverse skills the filtering is going to
be really important
all right okay so we're going to get to
that 7 Minutes 70% off coupon here in a
little bit let's go through this case
study first so right off the bat we're
looking at an image and I got to be
honest there's something about this
image that's like making making me not
want to dig into it maybe it's too
complex maybe there's too much things
going on
ux services are are difficult they're
challenging to make look good because a
lot of it is more strategy oriented and
obviously it's going to result in some
kind of execution whether that's a UI or
maybe it's like um an in-person
experience that you're
designing
but the actual research portion can be
tricky one agency that has incredible
visuals for ux design is Ideo and if you
go look at their visuals it's all about
the people and so they hook you in with
you know somebody looking at a whole
wall of Post-it notes or um a researcher
studying how kids eat lunch at school um
so those visuals are are a little bit
more attractive than what I'm seeing
here now there's a place for this thing
but the purpose of that first visual is
to hook me in grab my attention I don't
think we're seeing that here I also
think you've got to think
food chain of who's hiring
you and so who's hiring the ux designer
in a
company it could end I mean I don't know
the answer to that Ben so who would you
say are common people who would be
hiring ux designers at a
company HR I think if the company's B
enough HR okay HR perfect perfect yeah
I think HR manager is not going to even
if it comes down to marketing manager
right they're not going to understand
this because it's very high level so Ido
is a great example for all of you ux
designers and we get it like we we look
at ux capabilities decks and accelerator
and it's rough because what you do is so
Technical and it gets amazing results
lean into to the results and show the
research of it so so I just want to
highlight Alex here that visual would
look a lot better on the dark blue
background I I I agree I I do think that
that would improve it but I don't think
it would be enough to capture my
attention and I think it's because
there's so much going on on these
screens all right let's let's keep
scrolling and we have not gotten to the
code yet you have not the seven minutes
have not started yet so yeah get to that
in a second all right so we've got a too
long didn't read here which I really
like because if I'm in a hurry I'm just
going to read a couple of sentences and
move on and it's really clear to me it's
like here's the services rendered here's
about the client here's our mission and
then outcome and outcome is is basically
just what you did what did you make what
were the resulting items of your
engagement that happened so this is a
really nice uh to long didn't read
section now down
here I think the balance is a little
thrown
off I need more visuals there's got to
be a way to make this friendlier for
someone who is going is moving fast who
really just wants to see you know a
visual exp explanation instead of a
written one so you can see like compared
to some of the other stuff that we've
seen today it's a lot of type right
there and I think this is this is the
conundrum those of you that are the
impact play very strategic the writing
is going to be the easier part the
visuals are going to be you're going to
have to do a bit more with you know
photos infographics things like that but
it's the flip side too we see a lot of
aesthetic work that doesn't have enough
writing so it is it's striking that
balance regardless of what your service
is yeah and I think just a handy rule of
thumb it's
like I don't know anywhere between two
300 words is a little much to go without
seeing an image in there somewhere so
every one to 200 words I would recommend
throwing an image in here um and and
that's tricky right It's tricky to
visualize something that you're writing
but that that is the skill of a designer
and so um enlist one if you are not a
designer to help you out with that I
think it's really cool to see process
images so we're going to scroll down
here kind of speed this one up a little
bit um love seeing
sketches there's one and then okay so
this is the this is the
final
outcome 4.5% of the customer base
immediately upgrad to the professional
plan which sounds cool that's good um
here's one thing for you brand
strategists you ux designers and then
anybody who creatively solves problems
for your
clients these are really fun to look at
especially as a creative director I like
to see the way you
think but if you're using process
sketches to just throw an image out
there without connecting the dots for me
um every single one of your case studies
is going to read the same way so for
example what in here was a decision that
you made that was different than the
decision that they had previously made
or what was an Insight that you were
able to unearth during your strategy
session that's going to make sense to a
potential client who's reading this um
so instead of just giving an overview of
the process that can literally be copied
and pasted over to another case
study get specific let me see what
insights you were able to unearth and
how that impacted the final design and I
think IGA this that's that's a
connection that you should make
here you said something that I just
really want to point out in drive home
because it's something that we see a lot
inside of accelerator when people are
writing about their work can you copy
and paste what you wrote and put it on
another project and have it absolutely
go with the project if that's the case
we need to get more specific we need to
get more granular when you say uh we
uncovered insights what were those
insights we we determined the company's
Mission Vision
purpose What were what was that yeah
what was the Mission Vision purpose what
was it and can you get it into can you
get it into like a brand pyramid if
you're doing brand strategy strategic
work where you have like the purpose and
the mission and the and the vision and
then like goals at the bottom so think
of all of like the different types of
charts that you create for your clients
and show those specific charts rather
than just talking about them because you
might make them really fast in a
workshop and show that kind of picture
of that but you can also then go back
and create something to visually show it
in an infographic as well
all right one thing that she's doing
which is really great is uh she's giving
me a next step down here so it's like if
I want to read
more I can how a fresh design was able
to increase website conversion so if we
click that now we're on a different case
study right and so I think that that is
a really valuable thing to use or a tool
to use with your case studies is like
lay those breadcrumbs out so that you
just never lose anybody's interest give
them a next step and then boom call to
action right there I absolutely love
that there should be a call to action on
every single case study because you
don't want to go past the sale if
they're ready
man go for
it anything else on ig's
site can we just go up to her work page
just so I can
see yeah there we go
selected design work nice are you doing
that yeah it's happening when I scroll
oh I see I see and then keep scrolling
okay and then we've
got yep yep okay so she is showing more
that's it's some it's one of those
things where if you only have three
projects she has more than three and
that's totally fine like obviously um
but if you have that those three
projects you can get them onto your
homepage and you don't necessarily have
to have a work page your work button on
your nav can just scroll to that and
just make it easy on yourself like does
it just think does do do I have enough
projects to Warrant a work page if not
just keep them all on your homepage keep
it
simple all right and I just want to call
out one thing I'm sure that
this is a client project which is why
it's on the top of
everything aesthetically though this and
this are heads and
tails
juicier they make me want to call you
and so even with a strategic or research
driven craft like ux or brand strategy
please please please make sure your your
visuals are just awesome
so I would lead with something more like
this or this just because that's that's
a good point even if it's pro bono work
even if it's a personal project even if
it was a barter that doesn't matter I've
I've learned that sometimes it's that
personal work that you do just for you
know for
yourself that's the work that gets you
the dope clients because you don't have
a creative director you don't other than
yourself you don't have a client pixel
pushing you you don't have someone
else's brief that you're like oh my God
why why and then at the end of the
project they're like no I think I like
my old logo
Banner it's like that project even
though those it was paid work doesn't
mean it's a better project to put at the
top of your portfolio you can lead with
personal work and get dope clients I
know this because that's what my studio
has done and so you just just get rid of
that thought that client work is more
than personal work oftentimes it's the
reverse yep and and the crazy thing is
that with personal work you can control
everything so you can engineer the
product or the project to attract the
kind of clients that you want and that's
the whole point right so personal work
it's awesome all right so we've been
going for a hot minute let's go ahead
and pull this
over it's time
I think but if you guys want a deeper
dive I
highly Stephanie's course okay go thank
you can I tell you a secret about my
course that not very many people know I
don't unless you're in it when you buy
rock your portfolio first of all rock
your portfolio is on pre-sale right now
for
$74 but right now sh you can actually
save an additional 25% off because we're
double dipping with with the sum uh
season of savings keep saying summer of
savings I don't know why it's not summer
not season it's not summer but I live in
V I live in Vegas so it's always summer
here um so you can get an additional 25
the course is published we published it
right before this call so it's in there
but this is the cool thing about rock
your portfolio because it is included an
accelerator all of this content also is
over in the accelerator program you can
get accelerator for your first month for
a dollar when you get rock your
portfolio but it there's another trick
to rock your portfolio if you go and do
all of the work from the first module in
rock your portfolio because there's two
modules and then join accelerator you
get to FASTT track to the third module
of accelerator because you've already
done the work inside of rock your
portfolio so you're saving you're going
to be able to get as much done in that
first month if you just want to join for
a month as possible for a
buck but rock your portfolio is all
about building the work that you want
more of in the first module and then
hyping it with lead gen strategies
inside of uh the second
module
yep all right so let's look at some more
websites like wait what these people
waiting are ready before we go I saw a
question what is included in accelerator
so if you are in accelerator or you plan
on joining accelerator via right now you
want to join accelerator or through Rock
your portfolio for a dollar you get rock
your portfolio you get the legal kit you
get perfect proposal complete case study
paid in full
opsis I'm not leaving anything out those
are the
six so if you are going to join
accelerator either today Thursday during
our tour or later sometime soon those
are the six courses that we urge you not
to get unless you want to get rock your
portfolio right now and get get the
Super
Deal all right who's ready for this
flash sale code everybody should be on
the future.com
shop because this thing's only going to
last for seven minutes seven minutes and
and and no one gonna pay attention to
the next portfolio review because
everyone's gonna be everyone's gonna be
shopping so I'm gonna pull open our uh
our Academy dashboard and I'm I'm I'm
hoping that I can call some people out
as they go and check out yeah so drum
roll
please
actually you know what we should talk
about no I'm just kidding let's do this
people it
is portolio that's a coupon code it's
Supermarket Sweep time just get as much
as you can in the next seven minutes it
is 4:13 right now at 4:20 easy easy we
will end this sale he used to be a cop
calm
down all right so or 20
minutes prodct if you have any question
at all please feel free to
ask Okay so we've got Carrie enrolled in
brand Identity Design with made by James
nice crushing the deal nicely done
Spencer enrolling in lettering Russell
graph rock your portfolio congrats yay
thank you and I saw the question how do
we get accelerator for a dollar you buy
rock your portfolio and it's going to be
like
$54 right now something like that and um
$55 maybe and then within it there is a
coupon code to get accelerator the first
month for a dollar but I highly
recommend you do the first module first
save yourself some
time that's right okay so Denise design
thinking guide book all right Andre it's
going too fast it's lit like I can't
even keep up with it Mark goodkin
typography the code is on the screen
guys portfolio it's portfolio it's on
it's right there the code is portfolio
someone asked um for fundamental design
skills typography or logo design I
personally would recommend typography
before logo design if you are uh Balling
on a budget today and just want to get
one course that's right and the um I
cannot say enough about Matthew and
Cena's teaching Style and so
granted it is not quite um here let me
make sure I'm saying the right course
here it's style frames it's not quite
applicable to a graphic design business
right off the bat but the fundamentals
of composition that he taught in that
class are amazing and this is one that's
not in accelerator it's not in any
bundles so if you're a designer or if
you're interested in design grab style
frames seriously like it
is I'm I'm a big fan of of Matthews
anyways and and that course it's
underrated it's
underrated we got another question what
are the add-ons with accelerator just
joined let me run through them again
rock your portfolio but if you buy rock
your portfolio right now you get
accelerator for $1 for the first month
uh legal kit perfect proposal complete
case study paid in full
opsis hey Diego I see you pocket full of
dough might be an error
um mods can we just jot down Diego's
name and make sure that we get him the
the pocket full of dough oh no
Raven I hope I'm knocking on wood for
you
Raven you guys might have broken the
internet I'm serious things are just
like flying by it's crazy maybe we'll
keep it open for a little longer than
seven minutes we can make that decision
we are in charge um logo design versus
brand identity course brand identity
course does not teach you logo design
but it talks about developing a visual
identity for your clients um and if you
want
to uh oops that's not it it's this one
well it keeps moving where's it there it
is stop moving
okay there's keep people are in the chat
um
it doesn't teach you how to design logos
it expects you to already know how to
design logos right so if you want to be
a brand identity designer where you are
driving the voice the personality naming
messaging and the visuals but you also
need to work on logo design you're going
to need
both and keep in mind that 70% off is
only on courses resources toolkits and
merch um there's a different code for
for accelerator that one's good all
month long and we're also doing a tour
for accelerator so tune in y Prim
productivity asks I knew this was gonna
happen I recently purchased rock your
portfolio before today's call email
support and they will refund you like
the 15
bucks because we did not know that
seasons of savings and the rock your
portfolio pre-sale were going to overlap
and it over only overlaps for a couple
of days so just email support atth
future.com the code for accelerator is
thank you and you can take $50 off the
first month right I saw a question
here uh Carrie does accelerator go over
comprehensive pricing
yes oh yeah if you're gonna join if
you're G to join accelerator they don't
come with
accelerator but I would not put the the
money towards pocket uh I'm sorry
painless pricing or practical project
management because those are covered
within
accelerator um but you don't get access
to that particular product those are
like next level agency type products is
what I would say do you want to add on
to that yeah we go deep in pricing um
and also budgeting so we do a a whole
functional fin anal breakdown for your
entire business so that way you can kind
of see when it's like the right time to
hire somebody or um you know have some
data behind the financial decisions that
you make with your business so we do so
Spencer says Steph Ben y'all know me is
the made by James course a good idea for
me absolutely yep yes
absolutely and we know him because he's
an accelerator um football atie asks bot
rock your portfolio the coupon code is
in the very last lesson of the course
it's in there yep and that's good for
forever so feel free I would if you if
you jumped in rock your portfolio take
some time get a couple personal projects
under your belt of work that you want to
do and that way you're you're loaded up
you're ready to go and you can join
accelerator at any
point made by James oh man that course
is so good I'm taking that course guys I
helped create that course and I'm taking
the course right now cuz just knocked
out of the park Sandy asked oh hey Sandy
s's an accelerator analie's course or
James course are they the same analie's
course is very heavy on brand strategy
and not implementation of brand
identity James's course is not heavy on
strategy he does a lot of facilitation
and Discovery with his clients to create
the brand identity but he's not helping
them with their marketing plans are
doing heavy research user user re
research and interviewing and things
like that that analy
teaches all right we have come to time
so mods let's go ahead and take that
coupon code down you guys were have been
amazing I I the feed was going so fast
that I couldn't keep up and I'm I'm so
thrilled I mean honestly when we had
this idea to do these flash sales we're
like is anybody going to show up is
anybody care and you guys have shown up
in thank you thank you when is the next
flash
sale the next flash sale is next Tuesday
next Tuesday Tuesday that's gonna be
with with Carrie with Carrie and Jess
who are in the chat right now that's
right looking forward to that all right
so should we take look at another couple
of websites let's go all right who's
next Who's Next y'all thank you again
seriously it means the world to me um to
be put in a position where we can sit
here and help you all um just
from the interactions that we've been
able to have with our accelerator
members the the way that we've been able
to have an impact on people's lives
makes my job incredibly fulfilling so
thank you for being there thank you for
being a part of our journey
and uh yeah a little emotional gotta say
okay let me close this down you guys can
come hang out with us again on Thursday
we're doing a tour of accelerator if you
want to hang out with us more
yep all right let's get into another
website so this one is from
nicolay oh
dear this is my struggle welcome welcome
members n b that's your name now sorry
we're gonna go with Nikki B all right
Nikolai let's take a look a people first
branding and website design studio where
a multi-disciplinary design studio
focusing on graphic design brand
identity and website design
Steph can we understand what they
do I would get rid of
multidisciplinary I think graphic design
I think brand identity might be a
little too inside our
language design branding
web I think it could be I think it could
be simplified quite a bit I actually
think that the top statement is a bit
more clear branding and website design
studio not really sure what people first
means well let's see if we find out yeah
that that one is I think I might
understand but I I'm not really clear on
what people first means and it also
might be one of those things where it's
like shouldn't everyone be people
first so it might be one of those
statements
that might not be adding any Clarity to
to you to the
statement
yep all right so now we've got some
examples of
work and some Services okay
so oh see I went to click on this
because I want to see more of this
because look at that work it's
gorgeous but I can't so that's
interesting all right so they're
basically saying here's what we do we're
branding inside design and then here's
our
capabilities which is website uxui brand
identity and graphic
design right then we go down to case
study I see
okay wait a minute we've got tear
here
interesting so from what I'm I'm looking
at we've got an offer here for two tiers
brand Identity Design and website
experiences and it almost feels like
there's
there's like prepackaged
Services
which can be challenging for clients to
understand but we'll we'll get into it
got a solid CTA here book and intro
call oh and some testimonials
nice all right Steph where do you want
to go from
here
let's go let's talk about the offers
let's talk about the okay the the
tiers first off when I think tier I
think good better
best and not necessarily two separate
Services because brand identity is very
different than website experience and
someone actually might need both and so
I don't necessarily think this is a TI
tiers think like SAS companies the
better best um these are just different
things yeah these are just different
packages is what I would say um that
said if I look at Brand Identity Design
I'm gonna have to take my glasses off
because it's
tiny I just need to to like does every
client because because Nikki B has not
differentiated to a particular industry
or Market
segment it's kind of very open wide will
every client need a pitch deck
will every client need packaging and
label design will every client need
signage this is almost reading like a
menu of options to me rather than this
is everything within this package
because immediately I can already tell
that there are going to be companies
that come to this I'm like well I don't
I don't need uh custom illustrations why
would I need that I don't need icons or
don't need print design because I'm
totally digital so I think this is more
capabilities and when I see capabilities
this
extensive I'm gonna Hur I'm gonna hurt
some people right now sorry I say this
with love have you proven that you can
do every single one of these things so
I'm expecting an extensive body of work
I'm I want to see icons I want to see
illustrations I I want to see a UI
toolkit I want to see an example of
e-commerce I want to see an example of
wireframes and brand strategy and print
design now I'm not saying it's not
possible just double check yeah are you
are you proving what one of the things
right can we understand what you do
looks like you do a lot is there
proof right now I need to see the proof
of every single one of those things and
that is why I think it is so
important to start simple choose one
thing get badass at that one thing start
adding on as you go now I don't know
what where Nikki B is at in his journey
but just something for all of us to
think about when we are offering
something as extensive as
this yeah hey Raven I see your your
comment in the chat just do me favorite
mods if you could jot her name down and
Raven a few email support will help you
out here's the thing about these uh
about these Services imagine you were
looking
for
um a contractor to come in and help you
remodel your kitchen and you went to the
contractor's website and they had a list
of the things that they would do for
under services like
hammering scrap
in setting up
Nails
tiling that is not going to be as
compelling as saying I can help you
renovate your kitchen or this is what
I've done in the past as my services so
I think I think that when we get this
when we get this granular and
prescriptive with the packages it's G to
it's going to it's going to be
challenging for clients to see how they
can
how they can work together um especially
when they're grouped together like in in
this tier kind of layout that you're
communicating that these are grouped
together and I'm going to have to do all
of them um and it's not telling me what
I can do with them so I think just some
some repackaging of this information is
in
order all right let's uh let's take a
look at the featured case study here um
it's the it's the first piece of work
that we're seeing on the site
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
project all right so we've got a list of
services so we've got branding
Consulting website redesign iconography
illustration so we're scrolling down
here all
right
okay I was gonna say I I was hoping to
get to some details pretty soon here but
that was a lot of images in a row
without too terribly a whole lot of of
context now the Saving Grace is that
we've got some baked in type inside the
images but this is not going to do very
well for um accessibility or search so
let's get into this down here search
meaning SEO not putting your text in an
image because the Google Bots can't read
that yet y maybe
someday I think there's plenty of
writing I think we just need to get the
is that is that the whole case study
that's it yep yeah I think the the
writing itself needs to be moved around
within the images to give it more
context images context images maybe the
challenge goes up top and then all of
those Creative Solutions could be little
captions that go with the various images
yeah now I will say um we are getting
really detailed here so I know that it
it might be difficult to read on your
screen so let me read this real quick
for you the creative solution number one
is shapes colors and patterns we added
shapes gradient colors and patterns to
their design to create an engaging
visual
contrast that's kind of a boiler plate
like that that statement we could copy
and paste to another case study but
but they go on vibrant coral and ocean
blue gradients against the dark
background represented the dynamic tech
industry that's the kind of insight
that's going to hook a potential client
it's like oh you made those decisions
for a reason and so that's is a this is
a great example of somebody who got
really specific and surfaced an Insight
that that that impacted the execution of
the creative work
okay as far as visuals go that we we've
committed a portfolio sin here I done
this is another
bism that
is we can't see this
work having a
visual that we can't see and understand
what we're looking at and it's not can't
zoom or anything like that um without
you know getting in here and doing this
number to the website
um I don't know what's going on and so I
can even if I wanted to to zoom in and
look you're not giving me that
opportunity now I see this all the time
in
web you web designers are so guilty of
showing me a graphic of all of the
screens that you designed and then
showing me that same graphic over and
over and over again and it's like here's
one perspective of all all the screens
here's another perspective of all the
screens oh by the way here's a top down
perspective of all the screens we need
to see details it's okay to have an
overview shot maybe it's like you know
one or two times throughout the case
study but you also have to follow that
up with a lot of details about this
design because otherwise it's kind of
worthless it's a it's a it's a throwaway
graphic for the viewer I think another
solution for that is to like have a
phone in like a gif where it's like you
can see the scroll because you never see
the scroll of a whole like you never see
a web page all on its own you never see
whether it be mobile tablet or or
desktop so there's there's another way
of going about that I thought you were
going to call out the sin that I have
committed where it's showing the colors
and the texts yeah what's going there
that's what I thought you were gonna
call out and I have done it um so let
let's let's Ben so box go yeah okay so
hex codes mean very very little except
to a very small segment of of
clients this is Handy if you want a
bunch of uh designers to jump in here
and Rob you of your
pallets not so handy for a client and I
think that there's a there's a level of
empathy that goes into being able to
display color
palettes with enough context so that the
average human being that doesn't know
how to see the same way that we do can
understand it and appreciate it and I
think that the first website that we
looked at Daniel pole did a great way of
showcasing the pallet without listing a
bunch of hex codes and and throwing
blocks in there like I said this is this
is wonderful for other designers some
creative directors will appreciate this
um but that's about it and and the fact
that one of the leading images is tough
my two cents because Ben and I have gone
back and forth about this clients often
ask me well what do I
get when like what what are you going to
give me at the end of this and I'm like
well you're going to get your colors so
you know what to like the colors to use
for your brand and you're going to get
the type basis so you can keep it
consistent so for me I always thought it
was they keep asking me this I should
include it in my case studies but a
better approach if you are in The
Branding space is to show a style gu
guide that that you're delivering
because then you're showing it in the
context of you're going to get this
style guide that includes your colors
and your types and maybe some messaging
and all the stuff that you include in
your style guide so that would be
another way to do it if you're not
showing it um if you want to make
sure that clients understand what
they're getting at the end yeah but
that's that
context that this doesn't have if that
makes sense right you're showing the
color palette in context it's inside of
a brand book it's inside of a mockup
that's that's that shows the client like
oh okay I'm going to get to understand
this stuff that I'm looking at that I
don't really understand what those hex
codes are the context is key and I think
that that's the level of empathy that
we're we're missing just a little bit
here all right let's uh let's go ahead
and take a look at the projects page so
we can see the breadth of
work
okay so we have quite a
bit of work in
here and I gotta be
honest and you guys in the chat you let
me
know what uh let me know if you agree
but I see some projects in here that are
heads and
shoulders better than the one that we
were looking at
yeah I think this is the case of Let It
Go give it a hug Marie Marie condo this
situation guys give it a hug thank it
for its service it got you to where you
are now but it is no longer serving your
portfolio Let It Go
yep so I would say you know this one
this
Mark is probably when I when I look at
this thumbnail compared to
this they're too very different levels
of Aesthetics and I would honestly focus
more on something like this and then let
this one go and there's also things if
we go to the fourth optional criteria
which I love this criteria is like I am
I feeling your
Vibe I am with some things and then some
things throw me
off so not
always yeah I I think that there's a lot
of a lot of indicators here you know
we've got
like you sitting in front of your
motorcycle Vibe Vibe of apparel like I I
I'm I'm starting to click in here and
then and I there are projects in in the
portfolio that fit that Vibe yeah focus
on that yep lot of this stuff is so so
crispy and so
clean um that I'm getting two different
messages oh I love I love the values
this is this is huge great place for uh
for values on your about
page so yeah I think the name of the
game for you Nikolai is is just
refinement curation and refinement you
know um I think that that's the that's
the way to go can we go back to his his
Clarity statement on his on his homepage
the one that I wasn't sure sure about
MH still not sure about people
first I'm not I'm not really seeing what
you mean by that in the portfolio yeah
so something to think
about sometimes just a simple branding
and website design studio and get some
maybe some work up there in the hero
section so we can kind of get a Vibe or
kind of the type of work that you do and
the type of work that you want more of
your visuals especially if if you are
Aesthetics if you're doing any kind of
aesthetic work that's going to tell a
lot more than by saying people
first yep so check it out I want to show
you this website we are modotto they're
one of my favorite uh Studios agencies
right now and what they've done is
they've executed on the promise ideas
worth rallying around around right motto
is a strategic branding agency leading
the world yada yada Y and we go down
here and it's
like let's find your motto you have a
big Vision we make your vision visible
and
so all of this this content this copy
their values everything on their um
website supports the promise of let's
find your motto ideas worth rallying
around and so Nikolai I I was looking
for that with this and because that
didn't really happen um I'm left
wondering what that means and that's not
a good
thing but I will say the breadth of work
that you've got is is super impressive I
think that uh
your your portfolio as a whole could do
with just a little bit of curation a
little bit of uh you know trimming some
stuff up here and there and then
refining I don't think he's showing too
much
work I think it just needs to be paired
down get all of it into one spot where
you can see it and start asking those
questions skill was it a joy in some way
is this the type of work you want more
of yep and then from there you can also
add in like is this the vibe that I'm
that I'm going for and inside of
accelera and rock your portfolio I have
a whole training bonus training on your
creative voice if you if you're just not
sure what what you want your vibe to be
kind of getting that Vibe out into the
world
yeah all right let me look in the chat
real quick any other final thoughts on
uh
nikolai's no great
work everyone's portfolio needs work
even mine hey Ben where's yours
[Laughter]
it's h it's coming soon I need that
little dude digging yeah it's it's
something that I I talk about in in my
course is even even my portfolio needs
work but you can still rock your
portfolio you can still get really cool
projects with the work that you have
you're just it's always going to be
version 1.0 2.0
Etc all right Samia creators at Play and
scander mods if you could drop those
names down um you guys reach out to
support and they'll they'll get you all
connected um for some reason the coupon
code was not working for pocket full of
dose so we'll we'll write that wrong and
I see your I see your comments
there all right do we do one more or
should we call it here guys we had
planned to do 10 of
these when you said 10 I was like
there's no way Ben Burns is gonna go go
through all that so fast I'm a painter
people I'm a painter he's a painter and
I'm a pointer and we love
both I get to the point and he Paints
the whole damn
picture let's do one more let's do one
more we got some people coming in late
so all right here we go we are
gonna visible
Moon oh Aron is he here I know Aron was
he I think Aron was here I don't know if
he's still here I think Aron was here
somewhere around there all
right so here we have visible Moon and
we help you to get visible okay first of
all what a cool promise I I understand
like the the the concept behind that I
think that uh that's
really it's I'm I'm hooked I'm hooked
let's see see what we we do without
visibility your vision will never become
reality we're an agency based in the
heart of
Germany through uh oh typo trough
through the power of video marketing we
help valuable individuals and businesses
get visible and be recognized trough
social
media uh we have supported so far a lot
of great brands on their Journey here
are some of them and we've got the
brands
here got some testimonial
and
services and then I this is a little bit
about us right we've got passion
discipline
ethics allow us to help you get
visible some great calls to action
here hire us book of
consultation FAQs
uh oh okay Pop Quiz yeah folks in the
chat what do you see where is the
opportunity for improvement here let me
know type in uh type in what you've
noticed remember our criteria can we
understand what you do is there proof
that you can do this and is the proof
compelling what are we
missing what are we missing yeah there's
no nailed it Brett nailed it and I say
and and I get so much crap for this but
I'm gonna say it anyway it's like the
cardinal sin of portfolios is not having
one saying that you do something and not
doing it and I'm not saying Aon does not
do it because I know him inside of
accelerator and I know he does do it yep
but making sure that that is the most
important thing on your website is the
work and when I say things on social
media like take a pause on content
creation for a second get your portfolio
in order people are like oh my God she
said don't do content I'm like no no no
no I said get your portfolio in order
before you start going down the content
creation route and then use your work
inside of your content creation and
always be hyping your work and your
thoughts right rather than other
people's work and other people's
thoughts because being a creative
service provider is a way different play
than being a thought
leader nothing wrong with either yep so
yeah we're just missing work so I can
reasonably understand what you do um you
know you you help them you help people
create content in order to get them
visible it's a very results oriented
impact play you're going to help them
achieve the impact of awareness you know
getting visible in front of more
people I just need to I need the proof
and the logo board you know this grid is
a good start but we need more proof we
need to see the work um and I know aon's
got case studies and I'm sure he's uh
he's working on getting them up on the
site um but that's the that's the
biggest point of improvement that I
could see here um as far as the site the
overall site design is concerned I think
it's really nice Ian we got the
overlapping we've got we've got depth
because we've got your line length he
approves of your line length Aon yep so
you got me hooked as a as a designer um
but I just I need the work in order
to in order to make a decision
here all right and then do we catch the
vibe this says worlds to me viby like
yeah okay cool um and this this feels
like
airon this maybe not so much a little
more corporate little more corporate
little corporate um I don't think Aon
has ever showed up to an accelerator
coaching call in a
suit
yeah I mean he looks great you're one of
the b
d I I the the vibe has been weakened
with that and also one thing I want to I
want to throw this out there because I
see a lot of it out in the wild in case
studies and on um especially web
designers websites stock
photos stock photos can kill a site for
those folks who work in Creative
Industries and so as soon as I see this
I know know for a fact that this is a
stock photo so we really want to make
sure that um we are creating visuals for
our websites that are ownable they're us
right because there's nothing worse than
a bland stock
photo on a on a creative person's
website
so all right see like this much better
visual much better visual because we
know this is him and we're see him in
action which is cool same here
Vibes all right anything else on this
one
Stephanie I think we're good I do
like the high us book a consultation if
it's a I would differentiate if the
consultation is free I would put free
consultation yeah because because hire
us and book a consultation it it could
mean the same thing but if the cons
consultations are free I would oh it's
not it's
not since you have two and I am I'm
reading it like a person would read a
website hire us book a consultation I
don't know the difference between the
two without having to read more and I
used to be the copywriter for the future
and I know people don't read so your
headlines should differentiate the
difference between what hire us means
and book a
consultation given that they're both um
maybe it's like it's more of a done for
you and a done with you like we'll we'll
help you figure out your strategy in the
consultation we will implement the
strategy in um in the highs
section I love what Alex says here says
this is the opposite of the previous one
no work but lots of vibe it's totally
it's it's like that no thoughts just
Vibes and I'm not saying there's no I'm
not saying there's no thoughts here but
it just reminds me of that it's like no
thoughts it's just
vies and I know that he he has the work
so would love to see more of it um we're
getting questions about accelerator um
Carrie or Jess can you guys put a link
to sign up for the tour is that possible
because I know we aren't going to have
time to talk about accelerator in this
call not all of you want to talk about
accelerator in this call um but we are
having a tour on Thursday and for those
of you that are still looking for the
coupon code when you bought rock your
portfolio it's in the last lesson of
accelerator I'm sorry of rock your
portfolio the coupon code for
accelerator is in the last lesson of
rock your portfolio but I highly
recommend you do rock your
portfolio because it's the first major
step inside of accelerator so you're not
you're not missing
anything folks we have ton T of sites
that we can review if you found this
valuable I have a challenge for you post
one Insight one thing that you learned
on social media whether that's in the
comment below that's really easy
or throw something in a story on
Instagram and and tag us tag the future
is here tag me Mr Ben Burns and tag
Stephanie gold sheep
design I would love to see what you took
away from this and if you want to see
more love to do more but we need to know
that you're going to show up just like
you did today um that that you guys
showing up live has been absolutely
amazing thank you so much for that so if
you want more let us know Make some
noise and you guys great a great crowd
uh Carrie and Jess I'm getting questions
like how long is the code good for are
we still honoring the code because it
was supposed to just be for seven
minutes but I don't know what the ladies
have decided because let's be real
Carrie and Jess are the ones who are in
charge shorter line length Shor line
length all right everybody thank you so
much for tuning in we're going to check
out now let us know on social media if
you want to see more of these things if
this was valuable to you uh let us know
and enjoy your new swag and your new
courses and and all the stuff that we
were able to to uh to help you out with
to today and um again thank you so much
next sale Tuesday next spash sale is
Tuesday you can still save 25% off
through the rest of the month
accelerator Tour on Thursday if you guys
want to come hang out with us some more
all right everybody thank you so much
again we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
guys